Speaker 1: The trouble sort of is continuing
for radical Republican Congressman Madison
Katharyn, except it's not really trouble if
there are no consequences.
And yet again, it seems that's going to be
the case.
If you're wondering what I'm talking about,
I'll explain the entire thing to you.
Madison Cawthorn brought a big knife to a
school board meeting that took place at a
school in North Carolina.
This is against the law.
OK, a new New York magazine reporting last
week, Madison Cawthorn, the Magga congressman
from North Carolina, attended a school board
meeting in Henderson County where he spoke,
of course, against mask requirements for students.
While he was there, an attendee snapped a
photo of what appeared to be a knife stored
underneath his wheelchair.
By the following day, it was circulating on
social media and the school district notified
authorities and publicly committed to cooperate
with their investigation.
In the interest of the safety of our staff,
students and members of the public.
Bringing a knife on to public school grounds
is a class one misdemeanor in North Carolina.
But the Henderson County Sheriff's Office
announced the congressman would not be charged.
In a statement, the sheriff's office said
that the decision took into account the full
circumstances of the incident, by which I
guess they mean a Republican congressman.
Did it quote, although unacceptable, although
unacceptable, occasionally a person inadvertently
possesses a knife.
Politics being what it is, writes Olivia Nuzzi,
Catherines adversaries are not content to
let the issue die with the ruling from the
sheriff's office on Sunday evening.
American Muckrakers, a political action committee
that opposes Cawthorn, sent a letter to Pelosi
urging her to investigate the matter and take
appropriate action.
The letter includes further documentation
about when and where Cawthorn carries the
knife in the form of a photograph, a photograph
published in January.
The image taken by Gabrielle Adams on the
morning of January 6th is Cawthorn made his
way to speak to the crowd that would go on
to storm.
The Capitol shows the congressman's fist raised
in the air.
The letter notes that in the photo below Cawthorn,
there's an object bearing a gnarled, rounded,
metallic colored end with a black face, a
large hole and an apparent screw head bearing
a strong resemblance to the MicroTech SB de
Dagar.
The idea being that this guy is carrying knives
around all the time.
So remember that Madison Cawthorn also tried
to bring a gun in his checked baggage through
TSA security at an airport.
Now, you might say, David, why are you saying
tried?
He said he didn't know it was there.
Well, it was there.
Not knowing the location of your firearm is
a negligent act at best.
And he did try to go through with it in his
in his luggage.
The idea of, well, he didn't know that it
was there doesn't really change that.
And it was just a big oopsy, no big deal,
no charges.
It's cool.
Everybody won't be charged for the gun at
the airport, won't be charged for the knife
at school.
So we're definitely seeing a little bit of
a pattern here.
And it is against the law in New York and
in New York.
In North Carolina, it is unlawful to possess
or carry open or concealed any Bowie Knife,
Switchblade, Dirch Dagger or other pointed
or sharp edged instrument on school property.
Am I most concerned with this or is this just
a symptom of the bigger issue?
The bigger issue is this guy so acutely, so
desperately, so obviously has no business
being a lawmaker, period.
He has nothing substantive or valuable to
contribute about mask mandates.
He went with the knife to the school board
meeting just to say we shouldn't have mask
mandates.
He has nothing relevant to add about school
policy or any policy whatsoever.
And Cawthorn is really emblematic.
An example of the worst of the Trumpy in Republican
Party, along with Marjorie Taylor Greene and
Lauren Bobert and a few folks who have been
around a little longer, Matt Gates, Louie
Gohmert, who's been around even longer.
And this is why I see the 2022 midterms as
uniquely important as far as midterms are
concerned.
You know, we said the 2020 presidential election
was likely one of, if not the most important
presidential elections in a really long time.
That was absolutely true.
We don't typically say these are the most
important midterms of our time.
I am convinced that the twenty, twenty two
midterms very well may set the direction of
American politics into twenty four, twenty
six and twenty eight at minimum.
And if these people get reelected, assuming
they all run for reelection.
Marjorie Taylor Green apparently is.
We looked at one of her ads yesterday.
If Cawthorn runs for reelection, if Bobert,
they may have already filed for reelection.
I just haven't checked that.
You may know more about it than I do at this
point.
If they get reelected, it will be a real signal
of the likely Trumpy and direction of the
Republican Party and thus much of the country
for the foreseeable future.
And, you know, gun an airport knife at school,
it's all very, very bad.
But most importantly, Cawthorn is a guy who
offers nothing in terms of policy.
They don't even really hide it.
I believe it was an aide to Madison Cawthorn
a few months ago said we're not really running
a policy shop.
We're running.
I think they called it a communications office,
meaning we're about social media and memes
and images and bullet points.
We're not about policy.
And that's much of the Republican Party at
this point
in time.